this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the alabama platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below more about them in just a bit
the old saying goes follow your dreams
but what happens when those dreams are
actively crazy do you give up forget
them or do you press on no matter how
many people
you destroy for william walker it was
always the latter born in tennessee
walker was many things doctor lawyer
newspaper editor but in his early 30s he
began to dream of something else
something that should have never been
possible he wanted to become
dictator of nicaragua the craziest part
he absolutely succeeded in 1855 walker
led a gang of mercenaries into the
war-torn central american nation taking
advantage of the chaos he marched on one
of the seats of government overthrew the
rulers and had himself declared
president and so began one of the
strangest periods in central american
history recognized by franklin pierce as
nicaragua's legitimate ruler walker came
within a hair's breadth of turning this
foreign land into a vassal state that he
failed is almost entirely down to chance
famous in his lifetime almost forgotten
today this is the story of william
walker the tennessee boy who became
nicaragua's dictator
from the moment of his birth on the 8th
of may 1824 in nashville tennessee
william walker's life was saturated with
military history his grandfather had
been an officer in the revolutionary war
other relatives had taken up arms in the
war of 1812. from a young age the boy
grew up hearing tales of the call to
arms and battlefield glory an upbringing
that
likely influenced his later career we
say likely because little is known about
walker's childhood however we can infer
things like the probable effect of
having veterans in the family like the
effect of having an invalid mother a
childhood prodigy walker graduated from
university aged only 14. immediately he
threw himself into studying medicine
with such a zeal that some think it was
a direct result of seeing his mother's
daily health battle whether that's true
or not something clearly motivated him
by age 19 he was a qualified doctor with
experience working in europe already
under his belt but whatever force had
pushed walker to become a doctor was
about to come crashing up against an
even more powerful side of his
personality william walker was a man who
constantly craved change by 1845 a year
after qualifying walker had dropped
medicine moved to new orleans and
started practicing law within another
two years it again upended his life this
time opening an idealistic newspaper
known as the crescent there walker
managed a brush with literary history
first hiring a young walt whitman then
firing him over his anti-slavery views
not the walker was particularly
pro-slavery at least not yet in his
louisiana days the young prodigy seems
to have absorbed the prevailing views on
race but without ever owning slaves
himself or supporting the south's
peculiar institution as we'll see that
stance would soon change in the most
cynical way imaginable but all of that
is in the future for now walker settled
into his new orleans life running his
newspaper becoming engaged to the deaf
mute ellen martin maybe this could have
been enough maybe had things gone well
he could have settled down stopped his
wandering and lived a boring and happy
life sadly we'll never know in late 1848
a cholera outbreak swept new orleans
killing thousands among the dead was
ellen martin his fiancee gone walker
quickly reverted rather than stay in
louisiana he made his biggest change yet
the same year cholera hit new orleans
like a disgusting poopy missile gold had
been discovered in california now walker
joined the tide of humanity flooding
west an anonymous 25 year old swept
along by a river of prospectors gamblers
drunks and con artists eventually
landing where all the freaks land
in san francisco by now walker had grown
into a man of slight build standing only
at five foot two and weighing 120 pounds
yet he possessed an otherworldly
charisma far greater than his stature
maybe it was his clothing which brought
to mind a wandering preacher maybe it
was his soft voice rarely raised above a
whisper or maybe it was the eyes gray
intense seemingly able to peer
into your very soul whatever its source
this strange charisma would soon send
hundreds to their deaths initially
though walker's new life in san fran was
similar to his old one in louisiana
taking over as editor of the herald he
made a name for himself reporting on
corruption which briefly got him thrown
in prison and he got into duels with his
rivals one with a trained marksman named
william hicks graham nearly killed him
from 10 paces graham blew a trunk out of
walker's thigh leaving the young man so
badly wounded that he needed months to
recuperate it was well laid up that
walker's desperate desire for change
caught up with him again only this time
rather than simply move city he got it
into his head to do something far
crazier
he decided to invade mexico
as an ordinary person you're probably
now wondering how do you go for a man i
need to change my life to arriba let us
invade mexico
to understand this mental leap we first
need to get to grips with a bizarre
phenomenon filibustering today an arcane
practice of congressional procedure
filibustering in the 19th century meant
something much wilder using mercenaries
to conquer or annex neighboring
countries back in 1845 the term manifest
destiny had summed up america's
seemingly god-given mission to stretch
from sea to shining sea this ideology
had been used to justify endless
expansion west the annexation of texas
the seizure of swaths of mexican
territory at the end of the
mexican-american war but not everyone
was content to interpret manifest
destiny solely as a westwood drive
others felt it was america's role to
conquer the entire continent a role the
federal government seemed unwilling to
fulfill hence the rise of the
filibusters if the us wasn't going to
expand itself the filibusters would do
it for free launching expeditions into
sparsely populated regions and
conquering them with private armies
since most filibusters were from the
south many had the additional motive of
founding new slave states slave states
that could then be admitted to the union
giving the south an inbuilt advantage
but not all so ideological some were
less concerned with manifest destiny
than they were with simply setting up
their own little squalid kingdoms
somewhere between these extremes stood
william walker from his arrival in
california walker had been a manifest
destiny cheerleader demanding uncle sam
annex cuba by 1853 he had gone beyond
wanting to just write about it he wanted
to join in but with cuba a really long
way away he settled on an easier target
that summer walker traveled down to
sonora mexico the vast state that sits
below what is now arizona today sonora
has a population of nearly 3 million
people in 1853 though it was a wild
frontier thinly garrisoned by mexican
troops and home to hostile native
american tribes at the mexican garrison
in guaymas walker put forward a simple
proposition in return for the flights to
found an american colony in sonora he
and his men would take down the apaches
to which the mexicans basically replied
no thanks we tried that with texas and
liquor worked out garrison had correctly
devined that walker's whole plan was to
set up a colony let it grow and then use
his numerical advantage to kick the
mexicans out and annex sonora but walker
wouldn't give up returning to san
francisco he set up an office and began
selling bonds and land scripts for what
was then called the republic of sonora
he also began recruiting men men willing
to travel south to help forge this new
republic with bullets by fall he had
assembled a group of mercenaries nearly
50 strong a mix of veterans from the
mexican-american war and failed gold
prospectors all in need of cash all
looked set to go all at which point
uncle sam glanced over and pretty much
demanded what are you dang vomits up to
now filibustering you see was
hella illegal the 1880 neutrality act
expressly forbid the practice and
washington was keen to reset relations
with mexico after the war not let a
bunch of dummies provoke a second
conflict that october the u.s military
caught wind of walker's plan and
confiscated his ship but in the end
uncle sam's interference didn't change a
thing walker simply found a new ship the
caroline on october 16 1853 he and his
recruit set sail under the cover of
darkness in the direction of baja
california before three weeks had passed
they'd have conquered the entire
peninsula now just before we continue
with today's video a quick word from
today's wonderful sponsor squarespace
look it's the age of creation think
about it everyone is out there on the
internet making something we're no
longer just reading blogs or listening
to podcasts or watching youtube we're
increasingly making these things so
you've probably either got a great idea
yourself or you know someone who does
and when it's time to move that project
from your head to the screen in front of
you that's where squarespace comes in is
the perfect web tool to help you fashion
the internet it's whatever you want it
to be maybe the hands-on type lots of
opinions and ideas about exactly what
your site should look like great
squarespace got all the customization
tools you could ever want with no
technical bs to worry about or maybe you
just need something functional something
that works with minimal thoughts so you
could focus on your content rather than
just the coat of paint if so good news
squarespace has tons of beautiful
templates that you can use and once
you're done setting up your website
there are many extra features on
squarespace so your site can thrive
email campaigns patronage portals social
integrations member only areas analytics
commercial options 24 customer support
everything you could ever want is in one
place so when you're ready to get
started the next big project of yours
big or small it involves a website you
gotta do it with squarespace go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your new
site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and you'll save 10 of your
first purchase of a website or a domain
and now back to it
from the moment walker and his first
independent battalion landed god seemed
to be on their side they quickly
captured the baja capital taking the
governor hostage they then hoisted a
flag and declared a new republic of
lower california just like that walker
had become president of his first
country now it's important to emphasize
just how sparsely populated northern
mexico was at this time the garrison
walker had taken down was minuscule not
some vast army had overthrown with
superior tactics still such details
hardly mattered when news of the
expedition hit san francisco people went
nuts in newspapers the annexation was
talked about as a done deal another
prime example of manifest destiny soon
another ship bearing 230 fresh recruits
had set sail for the new republic many
lured by one simple promise walker had
legalized slavery walker made
establishing the institution a priority
a cynical ploy to shore up supported
home that done he established his
capital at ensenada declared himself
president and set about consolidating
his gains when a small mexican force
counter-attacked in december his
mercenary army was able to drive them
back for one glorious shining moment it
seemed as if they were on the path to
victory then the captain of the caroline
suddenly deserted along with his ship
and all of their supplies and that
shining moment turned to the color of
deepest doodoo and that mexican governor
then arrested while locked up on the
ship had apparently said something to
the captain along the lines of you think
those bozos pay well take me to the
federalist and you'll see
what a real reward looks like just like
that walker and his men found themselves
stuck with no food just a new ship
carrying 230 excited hungry men so the
army did the only thing they could they
foraged for supplies this being a lonely
peninsula foraging meant raiding random
branches and making off with livestock
this had the effect of turning the
ranches from dudes who didn't care about
walker's antics to dudes who were
extremely interested in hiring bandits
to kill him but rather than retreat
north walker decided to set his sights
even higher in january 1854 he declared
the annexation of neighboring sonora
doubtless this came as a surprise to the
region's residents since wark hadn't
taken a single town yet and nor was he
likely to as food supplies dwindled and
their leaders megalomania grew more and
more of the fresh recruits were
deserting the worst came when 50 men
left at once after walker threatened to
shoot anyone who didn't swear an oath of
allegiance to him still the man from
tennessee wasn't one to give up on the
13th of february he left 20 men guarding
the village of san vincente then he
launched his invasion of sonora what
followed was a harsh lesson in inflated
expectations meeting cruel reality those
bandits the ranchers had hired now began
a sustained assault on walker's ranks
killing men by the dozens the 20 men
garrisoned and san vincente were all
murdered others died of illness finally
with just 33 soldiers left alive walker
belatedly realized the jig was up rather
than go down fighting the president of
the republic fled for the safety of
america crossing the border on his 30th
birthday walker was immediately arrested
that october he stood trial in san
francisco for violating the neutrality
act it should have been a slam dunk for
the prosecution walker was guilty as sin
the fact that he chose to defend himself
should have just been the icing on this
increasingly mixed metaphor but we're
forgetting one crucial detail this was
the era of manifest destiny when nearly
the whole of society believed in
america's god-given right to expand
hence the jury taking only eight minutes
to deliver their verdict
not guilty william walker strolled free
that day a hero to the american public
but rather than just soak up the
celebrity he would soon have his cold
gray eyes set an even greater prize
nicaragua
[Music]
the 1848 gold rush had exposed a stark
truth california was really really hard
to get to rather than simply jumping in
a car and hitting the interstate you had
to either do a dangerous overland
journey or a dangerous sea journey
around the bottom of south america
either way
it took months at least it did before
cornelius vanderbilt got involved one of
the richest men in america vanderbilt
divined that he could make a killing
ferrying people between nicaragua's
coasts thereby cutting travel times to
california to the bone in 1851 his
accessory transit company became a
money-spinning machine doing just that
there was just one problem nicaragua was
in a state of constant civil war split
between the conservatives and granada
and the liberals in lyon nicaragua had
descended into bitter partisan factions
who hated each other more than they
hated outsiders to get his transit
system built vanderbilt had relied on
the conservatives inadvertently chucking
them a helping hand so the liberals
decided to play their own dodgy cards in
1855 they asked william walker to help
them win the war once again board once
again looking for change walker readily
agreed he rounded up a gang of 57
mercenaries whom he dubbed the immortals
and they set sail on may the 4th but the
grey-eyed man of destiny had bigger
plans than simply helping the liberals
in his words nicaragua was a country for
which nature has done much and man
little a land of opportunity ripe for
exploitation all he had to do to grasp
it was definitively win the war landing
on june the 16th walker's forces were
supplemented by an additional 200
nicaraguan liberals as one they marched
on the conservative stronghold of rivas
a key link on vanderbilt's transit route
sure a victory it was a feeling that
lasted right until the conservatives
started shooting despite coming from a
family of veterans walker was no
military man for the battle of rivas his
entire strategy was basically just walk
in there we guess they'll probably just
surrender instead the river's garrison
made mincemeat of them walker's
nicaraguan troops fled his immortals
were pinned down forced into fierce
hand-to-hand fighting by the time they
broke out eleven not quite so immortals
were dead and bible-wounded rivers
hadn't even come close to falling for
liberals who'd hired him the aftermath
must have been the most brutal case of
buyer's remorse in recorded history by
rights this should have been the end of
their partnership but with no other
cards to play they allowed walker to
stay on and good job too because the
great filibuster was about to pull off
his most audacious move yet the thing
with the battle of rivas was that it had
been so one-sided that the conservatives
were now sure that they were untouchable
so nobody in their capital of granada
was on guard against a serious threat a
threat like say walker commandeering one
of vanderbilt's steamships filling it
with troops sailing across lake
nicaragua and invading granada from the
waterfront the surprise attack on
grenada was well surprising for everyone
in more ways than one overwhelmed and
underprepared the conservative elite had
no choice but to surrender on walker's
terms and those terms showed the true
nature of his plans under the truce the
conservative army was disarmed and the
liberal army disbanded in their place
rose a new more powerful force the
united army of the republic under the
control of newly promoted general
william walker and while there would be
a coalition government and a new
president there would never be any doubt
about who was really in charge from now
until his downfall nicaragua would be
firmly under the thumb of the boy from
tennessee
[Music]
the following months were an era of
disbelief back in the united states
walker became a folk hero praised in
newspapers as the grey-eyed man of
destiny a successful recruitment drive
brought more colonists plays were
written about him in spring 1856
president franklin pierce even
recognized the walker regime as
nicaragua's legitimate government unlike
the sonora debacle it seemed this
adventure had permanently transformed
geopolitics but even as walker felt
himself an undefeatable god forces were
already matting against him out on the
coast the british empire was starting to
worry about this american presence in a
region that they had interests in closer
to home the other central american
nations were starting to give nicaragua
nervous side long glances worrying if
this was just the start of uncle sam
coming to sweep them all up into his
greedy arms the first tremors came in
february 1856 that month costa rica
declared war on nicaragua before they
could attack walker led a pre-emptive
strike on santa rosa only to be defeated
in just 14 minutes by march the costa
ricans were marching on rivas again
walker went to fight again the costa
ricans handed him his arse on a platter
once again though walker's luck somehow
held after taking rivas the costa rican
army was devastated by a cholera
outbreak unable to chase walker to his
capital and kill him they returned home
but this was just a stay of execution by
june of 1856 a combined force from
honduras el salvador and guatemala had
invaded capturing the liberal stronghold
of lyon when the costa ricans also
returned the nerve in nicaragua's puppet
government collapsed the president fled
for his life denouncing walker as he
went in the wake of his departure walker
held a sham election and had himself
elected to the post on june 12 a band
marched through granada's colonial
streets playing yankee doodle dandy to
celebrate the inauguration it was
vintage walker puffing up overconfident
and not a little silly it was also
followed by a selection of his greatest
hits as president walker legalized
slavery encouraged mass migration from
the usa made english the official
language and laid the groundwork for
future annexation by washington yet that
annexation would never come even as he
made his grand pronouncements walker's
regime was crumbling el salvador's army
was on the march the british were now
supplying weapons to costa rica but the
killing blow would be struck by a single
man up in the u.s cornelius vanderbilt
was livid livid with this punk-ass
filibuster who'd destabilized nicaragua
commandeered his steamships and handed
the charter for the crossing to a
business rival in fact vanderbilt was so
livid that he began shipping weapons and
money to costa rica sending mercenaries
south by november vanderbilt's agents
had recaptured all of his steamships
leaving walker cut off from
reinforcements as the costa rican army
closed in nicaragua's president did the
only thing he could do he ran that month
walker put granada to the torch burning
the colonial city so completely that all
that remained was a sign reading here
was granada he and his immortals then
marched out to rivas where they were
surrounded and so the walker regime
ended not with a bang but with a drawn
out siege a siege that only lifted on
the 1st of may 1857. that day a u.s
warship brokered a truce allowing walker
to leave rivas to be arrested and take
him back to the u.s to stand trial hours
later president walker left nicaragua
for the last time by this point he'd
been the nation's official leader for a
mere 10 months a strange blip in its
long and tortured history but as far as
walker was concerned it wasn't over he
was certain that he'd be back to reclaim
his country
the end of the nicaragua debacle played
out like a half-assed reprise of the end
of walker's mexican adventure just like
last time uncle sam put him on trial for
violating the neutrality act just like
last time he was acquitted by a jury
that spent the whole trial making
lovehearts at him this was followed by
months of celebrity as he toured the
south making speeches in which he blamed
the military failures on northern
abolitionists he also got to meet
president james buchanan there were yet
more plays about him awful poems one
representative example runs it needs not
a prophet or talker to tell you in prose
or verse the exploits of patriot walker
whom tyrants will long deem a curse a
brave son of freedom is walker and
nations his fame will rehearse and yes
if you're wondering possibly every
english lit major on earth just vomited
a little into their mouths walker became
so celebrated in this period that he was
able to raise enough money for another
round of filibustering setting sail in
late 1857 the grey-eyed man of destiny
this time aimed for his old enemy costa
rica only for the u.s navy to capture
him bring him back and once again put
him on trial and what do you know it
once again he walked free by now the
filibustering was like a record stuck on
repeat 1858 saw another army raised
another expedition launched and another
ignominious round of capture and return
to the u.s yet as 1859 dawned there were
already signs that the nation was moving
on once tolerant of walker's excapades
president buchanan now denounced him
where had once been fated across america
walker was now only welcome in the
deepest of the deep south yet he still
couldn't break the cycle never able to
sit still for long still deluded enough
to believe god wanted him to rule
nicaragua the boy from tennessee was by
now trapped in an endless repeat
performance a cursed actor doomed to go
through the motions of a predictable
play for all eternity
well
almost that summer 1859 walker again set
out for central america this time
landing in honduras but while it once
again be captured this time there'd be
no trial in america no friendly jury
eager to see their hero stroll free no
this time there would at last be
something like justice after briefly
taking the city of trio walker and his
men were arrested by a british naval
fleet annoyed at this american once
again threatening their colonial
interests rather than take him home the
commander handed walker over to the
hondurans this time the court returned a
sentence shocking in its finality on
september 12 1860 walker was led from
his cell tied to a chair and shot by a
firing squad he was 36 years old the
deed done the endurance refused requests
to return his body to america instead
his ceremonial sword was sent to
nicaragua a morbid gift of friendship
nowadays william walker's exploits are
mostly forgotten even a 1987 biopic
starring ed harris couldn't save him
from oblivion in many ways that's
probably what he deserves for all his
conquest of nicaragua was pretty
remarkable it lasted less than a year in
all other military endeavors walker was
a mediocre leader at best too sure that
god was on his side to bother with
tricky things like planning and strategy
and yet for all that there are ways in
which his story remains worth knowing a
product of his time walker was almost
like manifest destiny made flesh a
strange icon of a strange time when
people believe the u.s should absorb the
entire continent his name may be obscure
now but the lessons of his life remain
relevant to this very day
[Music]